ضرب أقوى إعصار استوائي يضرب
الهند منذ 20 عامًا اليابسة يوم الجمعة ، حيث
ضرب الساحل الشرقي للبلاد مع
رياح شديدة وأمطار غزيرة ،
ضرب الإعصار المداري فاني بالقرب من
مدينة بوري في ولاية أوريسا بما
يعادل إعصارًا من الفئة الرابعة يعبأ
رياحًا مستدامة
بطول 240 كيلومترًا.  في الساعة
أي 150 ميلاً في الساعة ، من المتوقع
أن يستمر الضعف مع تحركه
شرقًا عبر الهند ونحو
بنغلاديش الآن ، هذا هو أقوى
إعصار يضرب المنطقة منذ عاصفة عام 1999
قتلت ما لا يقل عن 10000 شخص هذه
المرة لتقليل الخسائر في الأرواح
للسلطات في  قامت الهند بإجلاء أكثر
من مليون شخص من المناطق الساحلية
قبل العاصفة ، كما
يتم تخصيص أموال لجهود الإغاثة والإنعاش
التي ستتكشف خلال الأيام والأسابيع المقبلة.
أعلن رئيس الوزراء
الهندي ناريندرا مودي عن مائة
وأربع وأربعين مليون دولار
للإغاثة  في المناطق التي ضربتها العاصفة وهي
تشق طريقها صعودًا وحول الساحل
يقول خبراء خطر كبير أو  عرام العاصفة مع
ضرب الإعصار المناطق الساحلية المنخفضة ،
يمكن أن تتسبب هذه الزيادات المفاجئة في حدوث
فيضانات واسعة النطاق في
جزء معرض للغاية من هذه المنطقة
بسبب العديد من الأنهار الآن هذه العاصفة
هي أول إعصار استوائي هذا العام
في شمال الهند
يحتوي موسم الأعاصير في المحيط على فترتين رئيسيتين
من النشاط في أواخر أبريل إلى أوائل
يونيو ومن أكتوبر إلى نوفمبر مما يعني
أن هذا هو بالفعل موسم الأعاصير القياسي
Nikhil Kumar CNN New
Delhi